the Chancellor spent 45 minutes talking
to the head of the Roman Catholic Church
Merkel is a Protestant yourself and
though the two leaders discussed
religious issues their talks also veered
into politics earlier this week Pope
Francis made an impassioned appeal for
global financial reforms after meeting
the pontiff miracle also stressed the
need for better solutions the service do
you want to finance milk regulating the
financial market is our main problem and
central task the fond of our business
links Longstaff that's one we're making
progress but we're far from reaching the
point where we can say that such a
derailment of the social market economy
will never happen again you don't let
soon after the papal audience Chancellor
Merkel gave Francis a gift of a volume
of verses by the German poetry flesh
guilderland and the entire works of the
conductor vilhelm court bangla said to
be one of the Pope's favorites Merkel
received a set of Vatican coins and a
valuable photo op in an election year